[Musique]
vous voyez cette photo ça c'est moi à
l'âge de 5 ans comme vous pouvez le
deviner
j'ai eu une enfance très heureuse en
grandissant en suisse une des choses que
j'aimais le plus et qui me fascinait le
plus c'était la nourriture à ce que
j'adorais la nourriture et pour être
sincère
j'adore toujours faim pendant des années
j'étais sûr que tous les enfants sur
terre avait assez à manger comme moi
mais un jour j'ai vu à la télé des
images d'enfants qui mouraient de faim
dans un pays en afrique à cause d'une
guerre ou d'une famille
j'étais extrêmement choquée et surprise
d'apprendre qu'il y avait toujours des
enfants qui mouraient de faim sur la
même planète que celle où je vivais je
me suis dit mais comment c'est possible
pourquoi est ce que moi j'ai eu la
chance de naître ici alors que d'autres
non comment est-ce qu'on peut permettre
à ce que certains enfants meurent de
faim dans certains pays alors que dans
nos supermarchés il ya plein à manger
mes parents essaient de me construire
m'ont dit avant c'était bien pire
il ya beaucoup moins de famine
aujourd'hui qu'auparavant ils m'ont dit
aussi qu'il ya beaucoup d'organisations
et de gens qui font leur mieux pour
changer ça et heureusement c'est vrai
mais malheureusement malgré tout ça il y
a encore beaucoup de manu tristan dans
le monde
en effet on estime que dans le monde
entier une personne meurt de faim toutes
les 4 secondes une personne toutes les 4
secondes et c'est surtout des enfants
ça c'est fait et vu que j'aimais
toujours autant la nourriture
une fois ma scolarité obligatoire j'ai
décidé décidé de faire des études en
sciences alimentaires et me spécialisée
en nutrition et santé
puis une fois le diplôme en poche j'ai
commencé à travailler pour une ong dans
le domaine de l'humanitaire
ma tâche principale était d'aider des
programmes de nutrition dans différents
pays en voie de développement à être
plus efficaces dans ce cadre là j'ai
mené des enquêtes pour déterminer l'état
nutritionnel des populations et plus
précisément des enfants afin de mieux
connaître leurs besoins et ainsi de
pouvoir adapter les programmes de
nutrition en fonction au début j'étais
bien naïve je pensais que ce serait
facile et mettre en pratique ce que
j'avais appris l'université mais en
réalité lutter contre la malnutrition
c'était beaucoup plus compliqué que ce
que j'avais pensé il y avait plein
d'obstacles auquel je n'avais pas pensé
et c'était souvent frustré pas pouvoir
faire plus les centres de santé que j'ai
vu était souvent remplis à craquer il
n'y avait pas assez de personnel et le
personnel qui était là n'était pas assez
bien formés le matériel ne marchait pas
ou tout simplement on n'existait pas une
des choses c'était vraiment difficile de
prendre des données précises et juste
sur l'état nutritionnel des enfants est
une des choses que je trouvais le plus
difficile c'était de prendre la taille
et le poids des enfants mais vous devez
penser mais non ça c'est facile il
suffit d'une balance est un maître mais
en réalité c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué
tout d'abord il faut trouver le matériel
et comme il ne sera pas sur place
il faut l'amener et ça jusque dans des
endroits isolés qui ne sont pas
accessibles en voiture
il faut donc le porter et pas facile
quand il fait chaud et humide
ensuite les mesures en elle même sens
tout un autre défi pour prendre le poids
d'un enfant surtout pour les petits on
utilise un sac qui est pendu au crochet
d'une balance c'est une situation assez
désagréable et stressante pour les
enfants et on doit faire en sorte qu'ils
restent calmes pour pas que l'aiguillé
gigote dans tous les sens mesurer la
taille ça fait c'est très compliqué il
faut une planche contre lequel il faut
que l'entente se tiennent debout bien
droit les pigeons et ensuite il faut
glisser un petit plateau jusque sur le
haut de sa tête et regarder en même
temps le chiffre sur le m pour voir la
tête et pendant ce temps l'enfant gigote
il veut regarder partout une fois qu'on
a fait ces mesures en un sens on les
inscrit les valeurs sur une feuille ou
non dans un cahier puis quand on est de
retour du terrain on peut l'entrée dans
notre ordinateur et enfin quand on a
accès à un tel internet on peut
l'envoyer envoyer les valeurs plus loin
pour qu'elles soient assemblés dans une
base de données est ensuite analysée à
chaque étape de ce processus il peut y
avoir des erreurs des erreurs de mesure
d erreur de copie et surtout tout ce
processus prend du temps et le temps
justement quand il ya un risque de
malnutrition de famine
c'est une des choses les plus précieuses
un jour je pas être un problème avec
deux amis et nous sommes dit qu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui avec toutes les
technologies qui existent
il doit y avoir un meilleur moyen qu'il
doit y avoir un moyen de rendre ces
mesures qui sont si importantes plus
facile à faire et plus rapide
c'est là que nous avons une idée
et si l'on arrivait à estimer le poids
la taille d'un enfant à partir d'une
photo prise depuis un smartphone cela
nous permettrait de nous remplacer le
matériel encombrant avec juste un
smartphone de rang des mesures rapides
et automatique d'optimiser tout le
processus de automatiquement mettre à
jour les bases de données et même en
utilisant les données de géolocalisation
d'un téléphone de faire des cartes
précises mais là vous allez me dire
c'est bien joli tout ça mais à deux gros
problème avec cette idée le premier gros
problème c'est que c'est pas possible de
mesurer le poids d'une personne avec une
photo ben on a cherché un moyen et
heureusement on en a trouvé un deux
chercheurs ont développé une équation
qui permet d'estimer le poids d'une
personne à partir de cette mesure clé
prise sur une photo on a testé et un
truc plutôt précise naïve à manger 5 %
d'erreurs et on pense qu'on pourrait
l'améliorer encore le deuxième problème
vous allez me dire c'est que la cie dans
ces pays il n'ya pas de balance ni de
mettre ni de sac à mesurer car encore
moins des téléphones mobiles ou les
smartphones mais au contraire vous
seriez surpris il ya beaucoup de
téléphonie mobile dans ces pays
comme vous pouvez le voir ici en afrique
subsaharienne il ya plus en plus de
téléphones mobiles il y en a bien plus
que des téléphones fixes
il y en a plus que des toilettes
approprié
maintenant j'aimerais vous proposer de
prendre quelques instants pour imaginer
avec moi imaginez que vous travaillez
dans une organisation humanitaire etc au
lieu de devoir peser et mesurer les
enfants en utilisant un sac une balance
et une plancha mesurez vous pouvez
simplement une série de smartphones et
directement à voir les mesures et ça ça
demande quelques secondes
imaginez combien d'enfants plus vous
pourriez mesure et grâce à ça et peser
imaginez tout le temps vous pourriez
gagner
imaginez tous les enfants ont pu ce que
vous pourriez détectée qui ont de la
malnutrition et combien enfants vous
pourriez potentiellement sauver
imaginez à quel point l'enfant se
sentira plus confortable d'être pris en
photo plutôt d'être mis dans un sac ou
vous contre une plancha donc lui ses
enfants adorent et pris en photo
imaginez que nous pourrions grâce à sa
améliorer les données partout dans le
monde et ainsi en avoir plus et plus
rapidement imaginez que grâce à ça nous
pourrions identifier plus facilement les
changements dans une population et ainsi
lancer l' alerte en cas de risque de
famine
imaginez que grâce à ça vous pourriez
identifier les famines avant même
qu'elle n'apparaisse merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]